hey 42 here it's no coincidence that in
the movies the williest spies bravest
soldiers and greatest military
tacticians always end up fighting for
the goodies
i mean it wouldn't make for great cinema
if the next james bond film opened with
double 07 getting murdered in his sleep
after being outwitted by spectre's
latest spying prodigy but of course in
reality war doesn't really work that way
and no matter who ultimately comes out
on top both sides will have their heroes
the subject of today's video did some
pretty remarkable things during the
second world war he saved one of
europe's most important people from
incarceration by infiltrating enemy
territory in a glider saved a million
fellow soldiers from becoming trapped
behind enemy lines by kidnapping the son
of a prominent european leader and after
being captured at the end of the war he
escaped from prison by disguising
himself in an enemy uniform on the face
of it this man probably sounds like your
textbook war hero material and he very
much was
if you happen to be a member of the nazi
party
the person i'm going to talk about in
this video was not a good man by any
means he was a nazi through and through
and the personal favorite of adolf
hitler but his story is an interesting
one all the same
full of espionage intrigue and the
unlikeliest collaboration since elton
john and queen of the stone age
yeah that happened
this is the story of otto scozzini
hitler's answer to james bond and a man
so notorious the allies came to refer to
him as the most dangerous man in europe
otto was born in vienna austria in the
summer of 1908. he was a bright lad and
after doing well in school he went on to
study engineering at university he
graduated in 1931 but an engineering
degree wasn't the only thing he got out
of his time at uni he also earned
himself a dramatic bond villain-esque
scar in a fencing match
and it wasn't fencing like you or i know
it this was academic fencing an
incredibly weird sort of sport once
popular in university fraternities in
central europe where participants would
stand at a fixed distance and basically
try to stab each other in the face
dodging is against the rules as is
flinching so unsurprisingly brutal scars
were common at one time they were even
coveted consequently many prominent
nazis had them
which is partly why so many villains in
franchises like the bond films have
scars too
anyway after graduating scorcini did two
things he got himself a job as a civil
engineer and he went to see a talk given
by some german chap by the name of
joseph goebbels
it was to be a turning point in
scorsini's life and he signed up to the
austrian nazi party that very night at
six foot four and weighing in at 18
stone scotzini was a bear of a man
combined with his intelligence and
natural charisma he quickly became an
important figure in the party in 1939 he
played an active role in the annexation
of austria by germany and he even claims
to have saved the life of then president
of austria wilhelm miklas when
scorzini's fellow nazis attempted an
impromptu assassination a year and a
half later the second world war began in
earnest and scotzini immediately signed
up to fight for hitler
his first choice was to luftwaffe the
german air force but he had a problem
the german aircraft in operation during
the second world war had little in the
way of flying position adjustability
apparently hitler didn't fancy splashing
out for the premium messerschmitt
cockpit trim and that meant scodzini was
simply too big to fly he didn't let the
disappointment hold him back for too
long though instead signing up to the
combat branch of the ss where he trained
with hitler's personal bodyguard
regiment by all accounts scotzini was
hungry for action and soon enough he
began tapping up his connections in the
austrian nazi party to get himself
transferred to the front lines once
there he quickly distinguished himself
in the eyes of the nazi leadership
earning himself an iron cross second
class and a promotion to the rank of
first lieutenant
now before i move on to scorzini's more
dramatic accomplishments it's worth
mentioning that had history gone just
slightly differently scotzini might have
ended up being responsible for the
deaths of a staggering 4 million people
during the battle of moscow he was put
in charge of a unit tasked with
capturing several strategic targets in
the city that included things like the
central telegraph office and soviet
secret police headquarters but also the
sluice gates of the moscow vulgar canal
that last one may sound like a fairly
random addition to the list
but the canal was crucial to hitler's
mind-bogglingly evil master plan for
moscow you see had the nazis been
successful in capturing the city hitler
had asked scotzini to open those sluice
gates flooding moscow and turning it
into an artificial lake
drowning the roughly four million people
inside in the process
towards the end of the battle for moscow
scotzini was hit in the back of the head
by a stray piece of shrapnel the wound
wasn't life-threatening but it was
serious enough that he had to be
evacuated from the front line for
treatment
for a man of action like scorcini it was
infuriating but having a bit of distance
from the chaos of war gave him the time
and space to think you see he had a
particular interest in commando warfare
behind enemy lines type stuff and as he
worked on his recovery it became
increasingly clear that he had a genuine
flair for it his ideas were so
impressive that when he'd recovered from
his wound he was asked to lead a newly
formed unit of elite commandos for the
remainder of the war scotzini led these
men on a series of outrageous covert
missions the most famous of which was
operation oak also known as the grand
sasso raid the aim of the mission was
simple to find and free benito mussolini
who had just been arrested after the
allied invasion of sicily which
precipitated the fall of the fascist
regime in italy the operation had been
initiated by order of the peaky blight
sorry
force of habit the operation had been
initiated by order of the fiora himself
and he'd hand-picked scorcini for this
most important of jobs not only was
mussolini an important ally hitler knew
that without him italy was essentially
lost
of course the italian leadership knew
just how valuable an asset mussolini was
and so they kept moving him around from
one top-secret location to another under
heavy guard which meant scotcini's first
task was to figure out exactly where the
man known as il ducey was being held
he solved this problem in the simplest
way possible he found somebody who knew
mussolini's whereabouts and offered him
a load of cash incidentally the money he
used for this bribe was made up of 100
000 pounds of counterfeit british
currency forged as part of operation
bernhard an ambitious plan by the nazis
to crash the entire british economy by
essentially bombing britain with money
but that's a story for another video
scotzini's plan was eventually
successful but there were quite a few
hiccups along the way not least of which
involved him being shot down whilst
flying a reconnaissance mission over
italy he survived a crash landing at sea
with three broken ribs for his troubles
eventually mussolini was tracked down to
a remote hotel high up in the apennines
reachable only by a funicular railway
and that presented a fresh problem
storming the hotel via the funicular
wasn't going to be an option it was too
heavily guarded and hiking into the
mountains would almost certainly be too
slow considering how often mussolini was
being moved
flying in was the obvious choice but
scorczini saw ribs were a painful
reminder of just how risky that was
and so he came up with a brilliant
alternative
since sound was such an important
element in the detection of aircraft by
gunners on the ground scottsini and his
men opted to use aeroplanes that didn't
produce any gliders
10 of them flew the mission soaring up
into the skies high above the apennines
on thermals before bearing down on the
hotel holding mussolini on silent wings
the element of surprise proved so
powerful that the 200 italian soldiers
guarding mussolini surrendered to
scorsini and his men without a single
shot being fired despite the fact the
german force was the smaller of the two
admittedly it probably helped that
plenty of the italians remained loyal to
their erstwhile leader plenty of them
can be seen smiling for the cameras and
the photos taken that day but scotzini
didn't care he pulled off an important
and dramatic win for the nazi leadership
two days later mussolini was fist
bumping his old pal hitler at the
fiora's famous bunker headquarters the
wolf's lair while scorzini was enjoying
widespread acclaim a promotion to major
and another shiny new medal the knights
cross
the mission drew so much praise that
even winston churchill expressed his
admiration for what was undeniably an
incredibly daring raid it was also
around this time that scorczini earned
his now famous nickname the most
dangerous man in europe
now i'm going to go out on a limb here
and say that in hindsight that monaco
might have just been a smidge over the
top i'm not trying to say that scotcini
wasn't a dangerous guy he clearly was
but he worked for adolf bloody hitler
quite possibly the most dangerous
hairless ape homo sapiens have ever been
unfortunate enough to produce to be fair
i should point out that some historians
believe it was probably joseph goebbels
who came up with the whole most
dangerous man in europe thing in an
attempt to cash in on the propaganda
opportunity provided by the raid
wherever it came from the allies
certainly seemed to have taken the
nickname seriously later in the war when
rumors began to spread that scotzini had
been ordered to find and kill dwight d
eisenhower just before christmas in 1944
the supreme commander of the allied
expeditionary force was forced to spend
the festive period under armed guard for
fear that the big german with the deadly
reputation was out there somewhere in
the darkness closing in on him the gran
sasso raid wasn't the only stunning
military operation of scotzini's
remarkable war he also led operation
long jump the nazis ultimately aborted
triple whammy assassination attempt to
bump off stalin churchill and roosevelt
during the 1943 tehran conference and he
successfully coerced the regent of
hungary to resign by driving into
budapest and kidnapping his son as part
of operation panzerfaust the regent
resignation halted axis power hungary's
negotiations to surrender to the soviets
which would have instantly cut off some
one million axis soldiers behind enemy
lines
plenty of other covert operations came
and went during the course of the war
some successful some not
but by 1944 the wheels had well and
truly fallen off the stuttering german
war machine scotsini's final significant
action during the war was in the
ardennes offensive better known today as
the battle of the bulge during which he
led a small unit of bilingual german
commandos wearing stolen american
uniforms into enemy territory
their mission was simple
to cause utter chaos behind enemy lines
by giving out false orders and
disrupting communications it worked too
as rumors began to spread that a rogue
enemy force was somewhere in the
vicinity disguised in friendly uniforms
the allies grew increasingly nervous of
any units that they didn't recognize
leading to multiple friendly fire
incidents and at least two fatalities
less than five months later on the 30th
of april hitler took his own life
and 10 days after that scotzini handed
himself in to the american troops
with most of the videos i've made on
significant figures from world wars the
end of the war pretty much marks the end
of the video but scotzini is a bit
different because in many ways his crazy
story is only just getting started
like many of his fellow nazis he was
tried at dachau on charges of war crimes
specifically for impersonating enemy
soldiers during the battle of the bulge
an act that contravenes the
international rules of war scotsini was
eventually acquitted of any wrongdoing
and oddly enough the key evidence that
got him off was provided in testimony
from famous british secret agent wing
commander forrest frederick edward yo
thomas better known as the white rabbit
yo thomas testified that allied special
forces had themselves used nazi uniforms
as disguises in similar covert
operations and since there was no
evidence scorcini and his men had worn
the american uniforms during battle
which was actually the illegal bit he
was ultimately set free
incidentally there's another 007
connection here joe thomas is considered
by many to have been ian fleming's main
inspiration for the character of james
bond scotzini wasn't after hook yet
though several european countries filed
their own grievances against him for his
actions during the war and he remained
in custody until those offences could be
heard in court but of course that day
never came because scotcini had no
intention of spending the rest of his
life rotting away in jail and in the
summer of 1948 he escaped from his cell
or more accurately he was busted out in
a strange parallel of his actions during
the battle of the bulge
three unidentified men turned up at the
camp where scotzini was being held
claiming they were under orders to take
him to a legal hearing the men appeared
to be american soldiers and so
scotzini's captors handed him over
without question little did they know
they'd just given europe's most
dangerous man to three of his former ss
comrades dressed in commandeered u.s
army uniforms
intriguingly scotzini later claimed that
the americans had actually been in on
his escape plot all along and had
willingly supplied his ss buddies with
official u.s uniforms to help the whole
thing go off without a hitch
it sounds ridiculous i know but
scotzini's whole life was fairly
ridiculous and it isn't beyond the
realms of possibility that there's at
least a kernel of truth in this one for
starters we do know that scott ceni was
in contact with american intelligence
agencies after the war after escaping
from prison he worked with another
ex-nazi called reinhard gellen who spent
his post-war years in charge of the
cia-affiliated
gallon organization it's also
interesting that whilst he did move
around a fair bit after escaping prison
including spending some time in germany
france austria and eventually settling
in general franco's spain scotzini
wasn't exactly hounded to the end of the
earth like the fugitive he was supposed
to be in fact within a few years his
life went pretty much back to normal
he was even declared officially
de-nazified in 1952 by a west german
de-nazification cause
despite never actually appearing in
front of them that essentially allowed
him to do as he pleased and so he opened
up an import export business in madrid a
business that made scotzini a wealthy
man
whilst most of his dealings seem to have
been legitimate there was one particular
export product that most certainly did
not appear on the balance sheet
nazis you've probably heard that a lot
of nazis escaped justice in europe by
fleeing to south america after the war
and it seems that scotzini played an
important role in helping many of them
to get there rumor has it he used his
spanish company as a front for an
organization called d spinner that's
german for the spider which is thought
to have helped as many as 600 ex-nazis
flee to south america where they dreamt
of initiating the so-called for frank
whilst official details are fairly fit
on the ground when it comes to d spinner
there's plenty of evidence that scotzini
spent a significant amount of time in
argentina during the period long enough
to meet with the president juan peron
and briefly to become the bodyguard of
his wife eva better known as avita
according to scotzini's own account he
once saved avita's life during an
attempted assassination
for which of course she was very
grateful
so grateful according to some that the
two went on to have a passionate affair
i told you he was hitler's answer to
james bond
speaking of bond there's yet another
connection here ian fleming is said to
have baited blofeld's specter
organization on d spinner in part as a
kind of warning as to what might happen
if nazis like scotzini were allowed to
walk free
during the 1950s scotzini was offered a
job by muhammad nagoob who just seized
power in egypt during the egyptian
revolution perhaps keen to get out of
europe considering the whole holocaust
thing he'd just been helping out with
scotzini accepted going on to act as a
military advisor while helping to train
the egyptian army in guerilla warfare
and commando tactics including
incidentally a young recruit by the name
eviassa arafat
scotzini's story is a roller coaster by
all accounts but his final assignment
provides quite possibly the most
disorientating loop the loop of the
whole runaway tale because in a plot
twist not even m night shyamalan could
have seen coming in 1963 scotzini was
secretly recruited by mossad now in case
you aren't familiar with the
organization mossad is the name of the
israeli secret service or to put that
another way scotzini a prominent nazi
who played an active role in the
holocaust went and got himself a job
with the secret service of the country
of the largest jewish population on
earth not exactly an ideal foundation
for a business partnership i'm sure
you'll agree to make things even more
confusing mossad essentially recruited
scotzini who was still very much an
active nazi no matter what the
de-nazification courts might have
decided to become a nazi hunter on the
face of it it was a genuinely baffling
turn of events
but there were deeper motivations at
play here rumor has it mossad had
initially considered having scotzini
murdered
for obvious reasons but that they
eventually came to the conclusion he was
more valuable working with them than
buried somewhere in an unmarked grave
you see back in the 60s egypt recruited
a large number of german scientists
who'd previously developed the world's
first long-range guided ballistic
missile the v2 rocket for hitler during
the second world war understanding that
it was only a matter of time before
these rockets will be pointed towards
israel
mossad initiated operation damocles to
disrupt their development as much as
possible and that's where scotzini came
in as a senior member of the nazi party
who had strong ties to the egyptian
military
he was not only able to provide plenty
of information on egypt's rocket
programme he also personally knew many
of the scientists who'd been recruited
to staff it
as for why scotzini agreed to betray his
former colleagues to help out israel
well it turns out that not everyone had
forgiven him for his actions during the
war and one of those people was jewish
austrian holocaust survivor turned
famous nazi hunter simon weisenfall it
was common knowledge that weizenfall had
a list of ex-nazis he plans to bring to
justice and scotsie and he happened to
know that his name was on it and so he
agreed to work with mossad on one
condition
that they make his name disappear from
weisenfall's list
during his time working for the israelis
it's alleged that scotzini was a key
part of a terror campaign against a nazi
scientist working on egypt's rocket
programme which included abductions
threats against the scientists families
and the posting of letter bombs that led
to at least five deaths it's also
alleged that scotcini carried out a hit
on senior scientist heinz krug executing
him in the woods outside of munich
before having his body dissolved in acid
to hide the evidence
despite the work he did for mossad
scotzini never quite denounced his nazi
past quite the opposite in fact along
with d spinner he set up at least two
other neo-nazi organizations the paladin
group and sidade
and remained true to his ideology of his
beloved fuhrer until his death from lung
cancer in madrid in 1975.
the funeral was attended by many of
scotsini's former ss comrades who showed
their true colours by giving the nazi
salute and singing several of hitler's
favorite songs yeah so much for
denazification hey
it's hard to miss the brutal injustice
in this story despite the many terrible
things scott cena did in his life not to
mention the countless terrible things he
supported others doing he died a wealthy
man in possession of luxurious
properties across europe he married
twice drove expensive cars and rubbed
shoulders with some of the most
important people in the world in the end
otto scorsini is a shining example of an
uncomfortable and yet undeniable truth
that's no matter how terrible a person
you may be if you have friends in high
places who consider you to be valuable
you can quite literally get away with
murder
thanks for watching